just on the practicalities first of all
of the NATO operation stalemate is a
word that people have used it does seem
to be dragging on William Hague has said
this could last until next year so
frankly is it failing no I don't think
it's failing at all I think three months
after the International Campaign Gaddafi
is much weaker today civilians have been
protected that first day when the air
attack started in Benghazi that Saturday
afternoon they averted a huge massacre
ten thousands could have been killed in
Benghazi and also in jabya and Misrata
and everywhere else so it is the the air
campaign is definitely helping to
preserve human life in Libya and reduce
the casualties considerably the
alternative would have been a huge
massacre almost a genocide in Libya so I
think we don't really the alternative
doing nothing and not intervening is is
not really an option at all otherwise a
genocide would have been witnessed by
now in Libya George Galloway that has to
be a pretty powerful case for
intervening it's quite surreal actually
listening to Neil at the news wall that
this is a country that were told is
virtually bankrupt our country that we
have to charge our children nine
thousand pounds a year to go to
university that we're laying off
hundreds of thousands of people in the
public sector because we can't pay their
bills
we're told over and over again by the
same government that is spending forty
thousand pounds a night on hotels hotels
for pilots forty thousand pounds a night
for hotels for pilots to bomb someone
else's country when our pensioners in
the wintertime are going
shivering people about surreal but the
argument as with the argument yesterday
on vaccines is that still in the world
Britain is a relatively rich country and
shouldn't stand idly by if it's
relatively rich Africans that well it's
relatively rich if you're one of the
children paying the nine thousand pounds
a year in order to be taught at
university or you are one of the people
who's suffering the cuts or losing your
job but that's not my only argument you
have the logic is overwhelming you have
made it clear already in the first five
minutes of this show this is a still
and expensively produced stalemate and
we're either going to have to pay vastly
more to change that stalemate or huckle
down for what the Admiral called a siege
and did the British people really want
is the place the basic point of of the
military commitment at the time you've
heard that you know had there not been
an intervention there would have been a
massacre and Tripoli a lot of people I
don't accept at all and neither does the
government because there are massacres
going on elsewhere in the same very very
same region which we don't lift a finger
to intervene we're not going to invade
or occupy or bomb Syria we had no
intention of stopping Israel bombarding
Gaza with the Yemen thousands of people
have been killed in the Yemen okay so
why the difference for Libya the
difference is because Libya is only a
five million population yet up to now
nearly 13,000 have been killed over
50,000 have been injured hundreds and
hundreds of cases of gang rape yet in
Tunisia which is twice the population
only 300 killed in Egypt which is 15
times the population of Libya only 400
killed Syria is six times the population
of Libya only 1,300 killed I'm not
condoning the killings and other
countries even one life lost in Syria or
Egypt or Tunisia is not acceptable but
in Libya it's a totally different case
this is a mad despot who is out of
control intent on killing half of his
population just to hold on to power the
question is did we want to allow another
Rwanda in North Africa or did we want to
interfere as an international and legal
and moral obligation to protect the
whole population called the Libyan
people that is really the question no
but there are mad despots everywhere and
Britain Britain is a small bomb I
wouldn't mind no I know you wouldn't
mind but it's us that's being asked to
bomb them it's us that Spain is the
international community is 34 countries
we're not resinous it's costing Britain
38 million and we are grateful for that
but Britain is not paid for the whole
campaign it's an international campaign
is that me speak yeah this is my country
and it's my ears why is it was your
country yeah I'm a British citizen as
well okay yeah well we've cleared that
up yes it's my country that's being
asked to spend 38 million
pounds a week 1 billion pounds by the
autumn to bomb what used to be your
country was other kind country what
makeup your life okay stay on the Swiss
a tradition other despots are killing
their people in large numbers we're not
being asked to neither will we bomb and
spend 38 million pounds a week bombing
them so the question is why are we doing
it for his former country stroke now
country and the answer is obvious
it's our oil interests that have
fastened our attention on Libya not
because Gaddafi was a despot when I was
calling him a despot Adam Tony Blair was
kissing him in a tent in the desert I
was there but anyway let's put that
music you might see that this is in fact
because the West NATO is interested in
Libyan oil in the long run well this is
a this is a very well-known cliche which
George and others try to put across all
the time
yes Libya happens to be an oil country
but that's not the reason the reason is
because Gaddafi decided to kill as many
as possible Libyans as possible to hold
on to power and if the international
community and Britain is playing part of
that but it's not wholly responsible in
charge of the campaign if they did not
intervene then we would have had a huge
massacre that you you said you believe
13,000 people have been killed how many
of those have been killed by the rebels
and by the NATO operation durables don't
what you call the freedom fighters don't
kill our own people these are people the
rebels don't have any right missiles
well it hasn't all been one way has a I
mean this is a war that's going on this
means the freedom fighters have killed
some of the people fighting on Gaddafi
side but these are soldiers on officers
using multi rocket launchers and tanks
and artillery obviously this is a war
but killing civilians the only one who's
doing that is Gaddafi in its security
briefly a final question I know you're
gonna disagree George Galloway where's
this going to end and um it and the
partition of the country with the
Gaddafi the dictators crew hanging on to
the western part and the Stooges of
international
imperial power governing in benghazi
this is gonna end and Gaddafi and his
sons being squeezed out by the Libyan
people mainly with the help of the
International Commission can I finish
please this is not the House of Commons
please don't heckle me okay me you
squeezed out by the before the end of
the summer hopefully and then the Libyan
people will craft the Constitution and
have a democratic government and get on
with the business of rebuilding Libya
which is much better democratic with
proper development and in good relations
with the rest of the world the totally
the opposite of the nightmare of the
last 42 years and Libya under Gaddafi
that happened to be worth having only
yes if the Libyans could have overthrown
Gaddafi themselves well nobody would be
happier than me we don't ask me to pay
for it
we leave it on that note agreement thank
you very much